Everyone knows Green Goblin from the
Spider-Man movies. But it's a special
few who know about his time in Spider-Punk's
Spider-Army during the "Edge of Spider-Geddon."
Curious what we're talking about? Keep watching.
Nowadays, it might seem like common
knowledge that Norman Osborn is the Green
Goblin, but the Goblin's identity was
once actually a mystery to readers.
From the character's first appearance in Amazing
Spider-Man #14, it would be two years, 25 issues,
and one major artist change before the
Green Goblin was unmasked. That artist
change even helped feed an urban legend about
the Goblin — one that has survived for years.
Amazing Spider-Man #38 was Spidey co-creator
Steve Ditko's final issue as the comic's artist.
John Romita Sr. replaced Ditko with Amazing
Spider-Man #39, which happens to be the issue
in which Goblin's identity is revealed. Goblin
being unmasked as soon as Ditko left the title
led many fans to believe that Ditko was against
Osborn being Green Goblin, and that this was why
he left. Spider-Man's other co-creator has
seemed to confirm half of this fan theory.
In a 2011 issue of the magazine Alter Ego, Stan
Lee said Ditko wanted Goblin to be "just some
character that we had never seen before," but
Lee insisted that would be cheating readers.
However, by the time Ditko left Amazing
Spider-Man, he and Lee were embroiled in
so many financial conflicts that Ditko's
departure from the title was inevitable
regardless of any creative differences. That
said, in a 2009 essay, Ditko not only denied
Lee's claims that he was against Osborn being
the Goblin, but says he always knew Osborn
would be the Goblin, and that he made plenty of
creative choices to facilitate that future reveal.
Norman Osborn is hardly the only character
to bear the name Green Goblin. In fact,
while he's the original, most memorable,
and most enduring version of the character,
he's only one of five different
characters to have used the name.
Just as Norman's son Harry becomes New Goblin in
2007's Spider-Man 3, Harry also assumes the name
of Green Goblin in 1974's Amazing Spider-Man #136,
after discovering Peter Parker was Spider-Man.
"Look at the little Goblin Jr. Gonna cry?"
The third Goblin is Dr. Bart Hamilton,
a psychiatrist who treats Harry Osborn.
Hamilton uses hypnosis to learn Green Goblin's
secrets, including the location of his hideout and
equipment. Visiting the hideout, Hamilton gives
in to temptation and becomes the next Goblin,
beginning in 1978's Amazing Spider-Man #176.
Green Goblin #4 tries his hand
at the hero business. Phil Urich,
son of Daily Bugle reporter Ben Urich,
recovers the Goblin equipment after
Harry Osborn's death and even
enjoys a short-lived solo title.
Urich retires after his equipment is damaged
beyond repair during the 1996 Onslaught event.
After returning from the dead for a few
decades, Norman Osborn orders the creation
of a genetically engineered minion, designed to
be the new Green Goblin, in 2000's Peter Parker:
Spider-Man #18. He dresses as the Goblin
and acts like the Goblin — all to help
Osborn convince the world he was never
the Green Goblin in the first place.
Eventually, Green Goblin became more
than just Spider-Man's enemy. How? Well,
as it happened, he was helped out by a bunch
of green skinned guys with pointy ears.
During the 2006 Civil War event, Norman
Osborn is appointed director of a new
version of the Thunderbolts, a group tasked
with capturing unregistered superheroes.
Osborn's Thunderbolts include villains who
are little nastier than the team is used to,
including the kill-crazy villain
Bullseye and the deadly symbiote Venom.
Osborn's leadership role in the Thunderbolts
puts him in a position to be in the right place
at the right time when Secret Invasion comes
along. Focused on the shape-shifting Skrulls,
Secret Invasion has most of Marvel's heroes
uniting against this new alien threat.
Osborn later succeeds in gaining the public's
trust by shooting and killing the Skrull queen
Veranke. When the dust settles, Tony Stark
is blamed for the Skrull infiltration
and ousted as director of S.H.I.E.L.D.
while Osborn is made the head of the
new military force H.A.M.M.E.R. From
there, his power keeps on growing.
When Green Goblin gains control of H.A.M.M.E.R.,
the Superhero Registration Act is still in effect
and most of the surviving former
Avengers are considered outlaws.
Osborn takes advantage of this situation
and forms his own team of Dark Avengers.
Most of Osborn's Dark Avengers are villains
renamed and rebranded as the replacements
for more traditional Avengers. Bullseye is
disguised as Hawkeye, Daken as Wolverine,
Venom as Spider-Man, and Moonstone as
Ms. Marvel. Noh-Varr, a.k.a. Marvel Boy,
joins the team as a new Captain Marvel. The
only holdouts from pre-Osborn Avengers teams
are the mentally unstable Sentry and
the morally questionable war god Ares.
Osborn's influence is finally put
to bed at the conclusion of the 2010
line-wide event Siege, in which Osborn
leads a failed invasion of Asgard — and
is finally arrested and imprisoned for his crimes.
"It tested well with focus groups, alright?"
"I am Iron Patriot!"
If you've seen Iron Man 3, then you'll already
know the name Iron Patriot. What you may not know
is that, in the comics, Iron Patriot originally
had nothing to do with Colonel James Rhodes.
Combining the design of Stark's Iron Man armor
with the colors of Captain America, Norman Osborn
creates the Iron Patriot armor so he can use it to
lead his Dark Avengers. The armor gives him most
of Iron Man's abilities, though unlike Stark's
armor, it isn't based on repulsor technology.
Norman also creates the American Son armor for
his son Harry, but the younger Osborn would
eventually discover that Norman did it just
so he could eventually kill Harry in order to
create public sympathy for himself. Norman remains
Iron Patriot until his plans fall apart in Siege.
He eventually escapes from The Raft and
forms a new team of Dark Avengers in the
hopes of recapturing his old suit and getting
his revenge on the heroes who defeated him.
He fails, of course, and soon after
resumes his life as the Green Goblin.
Norman Osborn's most sickeningly powerful
transformation comes at the end of 2018's Amazing
Spider-Man #798. Osborn is one of the first
people to figure out Peter Parker is Spider-Man,
but the events of the 2007 storyline One
More Day takes that knowledge away from him.
In Amazing Spider-Man #797, when J. Jonah Jameson
mentions Green Goblin's killing of Gwen Stacy,
the words spark something in Osborn and
cause him to remember who Spider-Man
is. With this new revelation,
Goblin demands Spidey quit
being a hero — or he'll kill all the
important people in Parker's life.
Osborn also attacks the offices of the Daily Bugle
and, after an intense battle with Spider-Man,
winds up impaled on debris. Spidey thinks
Goblin's dying, but the issue ends with the
Carnage symbiote appearing and bonding
with Osborn to create the Red Goblin.
As the Red Goblin, Osborn is more powerful than
ever and doesn't even suffer the usual symbiote
vulnerabilities to fire and sound. Red Goblin
continues the hunt for Parker's loved ones, and
Spidey is only able to prevent the killing of Aunt
May and MJ with the help of Venom, Anti-Venom, and
the Superior Octopus. Borrowing Venom's symbiote
and allied with his old friend Flash Thompson,
Spidey is finally able to defeat the Red Goblin
— although Flash is killed during the battle.
The 2014 Marvel Comics event Spider-Verse
introduced dozens of alternate reality versions
of Spider-Man. Then, in 2018, Spider-Geddon
brought in even more alternate Spideys,
including a Norman Osborn
version of the character.
Edge of Spider-Geddon #4 introduces the Spider-Man
of Earth-44145. In that reality, Norman Osborn
gained spider abilities instead of Peter Parker,
and even grew four extra arms in the process.
This version of Norman Osborn is forcefully
recruited into the new Spider-Army by Spider-Punk,
but by the end of Spider-Geddon it seems clear
that everyone would have been better off leaving
him at home. Allying himself only with Spiders-Man
of Earth-11580, the Osborn-Spidey abandons the
Spider Army and chooses to destroy the Web of
Life and Destiny that allows the different Spider
heroes to travel between other realities. After
Spider-Geddon, this character acts as the final
adversary for the reformed Otto Octavius
in the 2019 volume of Superior Spider-Man.
Most recently in the comics, Norman Osborn
has turned to the side of the angels — though
you could make the argument it wasn't by his own
choice. Shortly after being made the director of
Ravencroft Institute by Mayor Wilson Fisk, Osborn
finds himself in the crosshairs of a resurrected
vigilante. The supernatural villain Kindred had
brought the Sin-Eater back to life, and this time
he has powers worthy of his namesake. Rather than
just killing his prey, the new Sin-Eater can wipe
away his target's sins, which is precisely what he
does to Norman in 2020's Amazing Spider-Man #50.
While he believes Sin-Eater is going to kill him,
Norman instead wakes to find his evil urges have
disappeared, replaced only with remorse
for everything he's done. Understandably,
it takes Spider-Man a while to accept
that Osborn's changes are genuine,
and the wall-crawler beats the heck out
of him in 2021's Amazing Spider-Man #57.
Spidey fortunately stops
himself before he goes too far.
For the time being, Osborn seems to be on the
right side of things. In fact, he does what
little he can to help Spider-Man during the 2021
Sinister War event, but considering who he is,
it's probably only a matter of time
before the Green Goblin flies again.
Nearly two decades after 2002's Spider-Man
helped usher in the dominance of super-heroes
on the big screen, Willem Dafoe said
some pretty wonderful things to say
about his experience playing the Green
Goblin. Speaking to GQ in February 2019,
Dafoe talked about how the Osborn/Green
Goblin duality appealed to him.
"You could play the scenes where you
switch from comedy to drama in a line."
As an example, Dafoe singled out the scene
in which Osborn and Green Goblin have a
conversation with one another in a mirror. He
told GQ that director Sam Raimi even gave him
Robert Louis Stevenson's novel The Strange Case
of Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde to read for the scene.
During his sit-down with GQ, Dafoe
repeatedly mentions how much fun he had
during his experience on Spider-Man.
And it must have been worth it, too,
considering the role's considerable physical
challenges. In a behind-the-scenes feature on
the Spider-Man DVD, Dafoe claimed
to have endured between "40 and
50 hours of fittings" of the Goblin suit
before the design was finalized. Dafoe said:
"It was really uncomfortable to wear.
It was so tight and so heavy that,
after a whole day in that thing, you
felt like you had just gone 12 rounds."
Early in June 2019, the anonymous
leaker known as "Roger Wardell"
unleashed a torrent of supposed
leaks about MCU's Phase 4.
While many of these leaks remain unconfirmed,
it's only fair to mention that this same person
leaked accurate details about Avengers:
Endgame months before the movie's release.
Among other things, Wardell had some major
claims about the Green Goblin. According to
the alleged leaks, Phase 4's primary
antagonist won't be a purple guy from
outer space, but someone much closer to home. Yes,
Wardell claims that Norman Osborn will
supposedly serve as the next Big Bad of the MCU.
Of course, it's now known that Willem Dafoe's
version of Green Goblin is on his way to the MCU.
Dafoe will reprise the villainous
role in Spider-Man: No Way Home,
but it remains to be seen whether he'll
replace Thanos as Marvel's main villain.
Considering Osborn and the other Spider-Man
villains appearing will be travelers from
other parts of the multiverse, one of the more
likely outcomes of the story would seem to be
their return to their respective realities.
Not only that, but Jonathan Majors' Kang the
Conqueror has been frequently cited as the
true Big Bad of Phase 4. But it's likely
that Kevin Feige and company won't be able to
resist introducing their own version of Norman
Osborn at some point or another — and who knows
what might happen with him? Only time will tell.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.